donald trump has entered into an
agreement for a spec to buy the trump
media and technology group but of course
donald trump super polarizing person
lots of people love him lots of people
don't like him and so the second that he
is now able to create an asset that
trades on a public stock market what do
you think happens of course it becomes
the ultimate meme stock and people rush
in what we have seen is that the trump
spac which is being technically acquired
by the digital world acquisition corp
which kind of sounds like prestige
worldwide dwac trades on the nasdaq took
off at the end of last week started out
at 10 bucks and it ran all the way up
over 150
15 x this thing exploded upwards
and now what's happened is as you see
that just
massive run-up and spike that was all
literally in about a two-day period it's
come back down it's trading somewhere
around 90 to 100
and so quote unquote there's some level
of rationality kind of it's still up 9
to 10 x from where it started and so we
went deep deep deep deep
on the interwebs i'm just going to pull
up a couple of slides from the trump
media and technology group deck
this gives softbank a run for its money
the trump media and technology group
has one mission
they will fight for the first amendment
protections and freedoms of all
americans protect democracy and defend
capitalism actually a pretty strong
mission i think most people would rally
around and say hey first amendment is
good democracy is good capitalism is
good they have their vision statement
there and we've got the next slide here
that shows that other freedoms are at
risk what happened to america's voice
and it talks about twitter banning a
president but maintaining a taliban
account which again a little crazy and
then if we go to the next slide
we can see this is where it gets a
little crazy the corporate competitive
structure we have truth social which by
the way is going to compete with twitter
and facebook
according to this deck
and this the social media platform is
called truth so you don't send a post
you don't send a tweet you send a truth
which is you know again i think a lot of
people are going to say like oh wow
that's
that is uh uh
very uh very unique way to approach it
they then have tmtg plus and tmtg news
which is supposed to compete with
streaming platforms like netflix and
disney or news organizations like cnn
and iheart media and then they have on
the far right here this dotted line
which is that there's a long-term
opportunity to actually build the tmtg
tech stack to go compete with aws google
cloud stripe and azure
pretty ambitious then we go the next
slide we can see that
i don't know what this slide was
supposed to be for but it is a massive
market opportunity all of earth can fit
in the market opportunity uh
very very big market opportunity
obviously if we go to the next slide
we can see that they're trying to build
an inclusive big tent approach and what
they essentially are looking at here is
can they build tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of people to bring
both liberals independents and
conservatives all under one tent all are
welcome according to this slide go to
the next one
they're galvanizing a conservative media
universe
and so they have asteroids all coming
towards the tmtg earth
which i don't know if that's good or bad
actually now that i'm looking at it and
then if we go to the next one
what is tmtg plus they want to compete
with netflix disney and hulu they want
to basically have streaming news etc and
so when we start to think about this
what's our general thoughts on this
stock and uh kind of just going from you
know 10 bucks to 150 like is it the
biggest like duh we should have
predicted that it's a meme stock
i mean look the goal is great right if
you can build a company that encompasses
all those things bro they want to be the
best company in the world
like the goal i love it you're very
aspirational do i think that's going to
happen within the next 20 years no
that's the most beautiful deck ever the
most beautiful deck
did any of your friends buy it
no do you know any of your friends about
it i'm not friends with idiots i i i
know i know somebody who work i don't
want to say their name but they work at
a very well respected financial firm and
they told me that no somebody who sits
near them bought options on it and made
a ton of money on friday and he
basically was like dude what the hell
like you didn't tell me that the options
were priced at whatever and the whole
thing was he was just like yeah of
course like look at who's involved in
this of course it's gonna go up in price
like you know this is like literally the
meme stock of all meme stocks of course
they're gonna push it up and so i think
what you start to get is you get a bunch
of people uh that are trying to um make
money they're not necessarily buying it
because they believe there's gonna be
long-standing value with